こんにちははじめしゃちょーです3日間
落ちてるものしか食べれない生活
やってまいりましたこの日がはじめ社長の
畑っていうチャンネルがあるんですけども
そこである男が3日間レシートに書いて
あるものしか食べれない生活みたいなのを
やってまして本人来てますどうぞ
やるんですかいや俺はそれを超えたいと
思ってるあなたがやってたのは3日間落ち
てるレシートを拾ってそこに書いてある
ものしか食べれないってやつでしょそう
です書いてあるものは絶対食べなきゃいけ
ないんですよ
あれはきつかったマジできついです食べ
たくないものとか嫌いなもの拾っても食べ
なきゃいけないってルールしてたんでその
代わり自分で好きなタイミングでやめれる
んですよ今日の分はもうストップみたいな
なるほどねっていうその掛け具合もあって
ってことは俺今日やりたいのは落ちてる
ものを食べるってやつをやりたいです簡単
にルール説明するともちろん例えばよL
チケが落ちてるじゃん
衛生的には絶対食べれないのでそれを
食べるわけじゃなくてそれと同じものを
買って食べるっていうレシート
探した時落ちてた
意外と落ちてます
になると思うんでゴミ拾いも含め3日間
落ちてるものだけでちょっと生活していき
たいと思いますというわけでルールのお
さらいしましょうルール3日間落ちてた
ものと同じものを買って自分で食べますで
落ちてるまで見つけた瞬間絶対それを買わ
なきゃいけない食べなきゃいけないという
ルールでやめたい時はいつでもやめれると
いう感じで朝昼晩やろうと思ってるんです
けども朝いっぱい取れたら例えば昼やら
ないとか夜やらないとかこれ1日2食とか
なんでひょっとしたら1日1回2回の可能
性ありますお腹空いてたら3回やりますと
いうわけで3日間でどれくらい食べ物の
ゴミが落ちてるのか僕の地域の民度が問わ
れますまたオレンジの近く海とかがある
から海に遊びに来た人がひょっとしたら
クソみたいな人間だったらゴミがたくさん
落ちてるかもしれませんそれをしっかり
拾って海をきれいにしていきたいと思い
ます
はいというわけで早速1日目スタートです
よし行こう結構結構お腹空いてます
オレンジの特徴としては海が近いんですよ
で波風でめっちゃゴミ来るよね来ますね
最悪なよなんか俺んちの周りに焼きそばの
ゴミとか置いてあってあったかも俺が捨て
たかのようなその感じえマジでやばいよね
結構
嫌がらせレベル誰がやってんじゃないかと
思ってます今のところあれ
これとかも絶対俺じゃない
キャンペーンの紙とか家の間にこっち側を
見ていきましょうなんかないかな
おい見ろポケカが死んでやるぞポケカが
落ちてますブースターユニバースこの上げ
方俺じゃないなこれ俺じゃないよ
怪しいふざけんだって俺これ開封動画撮っ
たの東京だったから俺ではない絶対ない
ですね俺は基本黒マスクしかつけないんや
これも俺じゃないどうする例えばなんだ
けどペヤング焼きそばのなんか袋の破片と
かだったらどうしますそのものってを確定
で分かったら食べなきゃいけないあー
okokok
今のところボランティア活動ですよこう
いうところに
いやなかったです家の周りいいのか悪いの
か
これ飯見つかるちょっと家の前でなかった
んですけども海沿い人が海に来るんです
けどもそいつらがクズ人間だったら
たくさんゴミ捨ててるかもしれません行き
ましょうというわけで海に来ました
めっちゃ綺麗でしょどう
[音楽]
あー違う
撮影してるね
よろしくお願いします
タバコ吸ってるなクソが俺ここから
フィーバータイムだと思ってるから結構
ライターです
綺麗なんだけど家の周り
[拍手]
あったあったあったあった見ろ見ろ見ろ
あったあったあります皆さん見て
牧場の朝ありました
ヨーグルトですなんか小学校の時食べた
記憶あるなこれでもこれが売ってるかどう
かってことでしょこれ多分スーパーとかな
んだろうなよしよしよしまずは超速で
ヨーグルトゲットしましたよあわよくば
なんか飲み物とか欲しいよねじゃあ俺
飲み物とかもさ落ちてるものだけそうです
水もダメですかはいせめて飲み物だけは
回収したいです
よありですいやこんなんもう漂流物流
じゃん
[拍手]
普通ゴミコロコロしてるイメージない
綺麗だな皆さんありがとうございます綺麗
にしていただいて限りなく綺麗だなこれ
掃除されてる何にもないよ
これわかめとかあったら
わかめはゴミじゃないから大丈夫
サバイバル生活
ゴミを食べるっていうのがテーマなので
ワサビとか海藻もそれ食べませんない見て
ない
[音楽]
タバコ捨ててあるよタバコこういうの見る
とちょっとねふざけになってなるよタバコ
吸うな海でボケナスがここはシガレット
食べとれ
チェルシー
チェルシーの
ヨーグルトですまたヨーグルトこれも食べ
なきゃってことだもんこれヨーグルトと
チェルシーのヨーグルトしか見つかった
いやありがたい食べます飲み物
おっと
飲み物だ来た来た来た来たホット
ゲットしましたよしよしよしよしよしいい
んじゃないですかなんか
あんまねえな家の周り
初めて社長のお家の海の周りはきれいな
ことが分かりましたはいというわけで朝食
がこんなまで一回ストップです一応帰り道
も取っておきますなんか落ちてたら強制で
食べなきゃいけないんでね
落ちてる
[音楽]
やばいやばいやばいやばいやばいやばい
やばいやばいやばい見つかっちゃったこれ
逆にありがたいまであるぞコカコーラ
見つけました家にたくさんあるなんか
どうせだったらもっとガッツリしたもの
食べたいよね弁当とかもしれないから弁当
[音楽]
三角
ケーキサンドのイチゴジャパンの
マーガリン
良かった超速っぽいよパンとヨーグルト
ゲットしました
[音楽]
というわけで無事に全部買ってきました
夕方ですあのねコンビニとかで売ってない
ものがマジで見つけるの大変
牧場の朝とかマジでスーパーでしか売って
ないしミニストップ3行目とこれ見つかっ
たし
チェルシーに関してはもうスーパー3か所
行ってきたで5号店をパッケージとも
変わってたんですけども多分同じですじゃ
いただきますまずはコーラでしょ
[音楽]
これ夜ご飯日が暮れる前に探しに行った方
がいいなぁじゃあヨーグルトいただきます
ああなんか小学校を感じるわごちそうさま
でした洗濯ケーキスタンドいやこれが
メインですよいや本当はもっとしっかりし
たさ弁当とかお米とか食べたかったんです
けど落ちてたものしか見ないのでもうやむ
を得ませんありがとういただきましょう
これもね全てのミニストップ言ってるわけ
じゃなかったから大変だったねいただき
ます
うんうまい
[音楽]
もう
移動に時間がかかりすぎて生ぬるくなっ
てる
[音楽]
少ないなやっぱ少ないよこれだとデザート
はチェルシーのヨーグルトです
うまっ入ってるけど飲み物はちょっと編集
中とか仕事中に飲ませていただきます
ちょっと夜ご飯は日が暮れる前にもう1回
探しに行こうかなと思いますでは1日目の
夕方ですだいぶね日も暮れてきました
海沿いはもうないのでちょっとオレンジの
近くに公園があるのでそこでゴミ探して
いきたいと思います割と腹減ってます暗く
なる前に集めないとね行こう多分マジで
すき家の牛丼のゴミをつけてほしい公園
って人がたくさん来るんでワンちゃん
ビッグちゃん作るかもしれません
こんにちは
近所の子供たち
[音楽]
ありがとうどうして
俺これ今日の夜ご飯探してんだ
そうですか夜ご飯
探してんだ俺みんな寒いから気をつけろよ
見てるありがとう
手に入りました色々落ちてたけどちょっと
戻れねえなあれたら公園つきましたここ
ですね俺的にこの公園でどれだけ手に入る
かの気がしてますポイ捨てするのってお
菓子が多いよね
待って待って待ってボーナススポットある
んだけどおいここやばいぞちょっとまず
こちらフルフルーツパークリング
ゼリーこれ見つけたの全部だもんねこれは
ちょっと何か特定できないのでノー
カウントマスクステンなボケうわうわ
やばいこれももう確定ってことでしょう
ボスのカフェオレ何これ
うわーきさん太郎これうちの冷蔵庫にある
わリフレッシュショットマスクしてんな
クズ
シャリモニックちょっと待って待ってもう
嫌だ夜ご飯やばいってこれ今
だったらまた飲めるぜコカコーラのゼロが
何でこのマスクしてるかないやちょっと
近所に売ってるかわかんないですけど
北海道からお届けちゃんとポテトチップ
食べなさる
豚丼味
八ツ橋なら来た30%引きで買ったん
だろうなパスコのチョコチップメロンパン
[音楽]
マルちゃんの昔ながらの中華そばの味噌味
これでかくねラーメンだ今晩は
わからん様のメール来てますこれダイソン
のゴミ袋ごめんなさいある程度掃除もし
ますここやばいね今で結構もうラーメンも
手に入ったしメロンパンも手に入った
夜ご飯的にはだいぶイヤホンなんじゃない
かなちょっと一応公園ぐるっとしてみるね
怖いちょっともうねここまで来ると取りに
行くのが怖い
終わりましょう
嫌だもうないことを願うよ
なんかあったなんかあったよ
これは助かります
マカロニサラダ
めっちゃいいですね
メインディッシュとサラダもついてきます
から今晩は
ただ1日目でこれだけ回収しちゃうと2日
目3日目食べるものなくなる可能性ある
からちょっと怖いね跡がとりあえず今日で
この公園は制覇しちゃいますいやもうない
と思いたい
やべえの見つけたんだけどワンピースの
シールウエハース
ワンピースのシルエハース2個目
友達と買ったんだろうねこれ俺2枚食わな
きゃってことでしょそうですマスクだから
さちゃんともう使えるやありましたあり
ましたよクラフトボスの
抹茶ラテやばいやばいやばいやばい
また見つけちゃったよ
ゼリー3つ目だマジでやばい
ストップでここでストップしておきます
これ多分また買うのに時間がかかるので
これを全部集めて夜ご飯にしたいと思い
ますでは
というわけで夜ご飯です今日も1日頑張っ
た時間はもう今9時半ぐらいですねよく逆
に集まってよこれも3つも完璧だしワン
ピースもちょっとあったしマカロニサラダ
ただねポテチが全く同じのがなかったんで
メーカーは一緒かな味が違うけど似たよう
なやつ見つけてきましたこれにします
ちょっとこれ明日もしばらく持ちそうだな
これだけあれば3本あるからこれから
飲もうかないただきます
[音楽]
じゃあちょっとラーメン作っていこうと
思います
やばいやばいやばいやばいやばいやばい
ラーメン完成しましたこれで今日の夜ご飯
が整ったラーメンあればまあご飯ぽいので
かなりいい方かなと思います初日はね着実
にオレンジの周りからゴミは減ってきて
いる明日明後日はたして生き延びれるのか
頑張りたいと思いますいただきます
[音楽]
お店のラーメンよりうまい
王様
[音楽]
チョコバットいただきますすいません1個
忘れてましたペプシのリフレッシュ
ショットもありましたね
飲めるよさすがに飲み物これはきついわ
食べ物はちょっと食べるんですけど
ちょっと飲み物はこの後もまた編集とか
すると思うんで明日の朝とかも飲みます
ちょっとじっくりと伸ばしてください
[音楽]
いただきます
ワンピース開けますルフィ
ー
ミスター2ボンクレー
[音楽]
あもう無理だ俺は明日の朝ご飯にしようか
な普通に飲み物こんだけ飲んだ時点で結構
あのー
ゴミを探しに行かなくていい気がします
ちょっともうお腹いっぱいなので今日は
これぐらいにしておきますごちそうさま
でしたまた明日
おはようございます2日目の朝ですさあ
食べていきましょう朝はしっかりボスの
カフェオレ
ここにあるもの以外食べれないのでマジで
お腹減ってるいやちょっとそろそろまとも
なものが食べたいですね
ラーメンも良かったんですけど
米かハンバーグが食べたいやっぱりお菓子
が多いんだよなお菓子のゴミって小さいか
な気持ち的に捨てやすいんでしょうねマジ
で許せない人間のクズか
あります
俺1回もないいいことがないと思ってる
後輩のリュックとかにゴミ入れたことある
けど
[音楽]
いただきます
うん
[音楽]
あとこれぐらいなのでちょっと食べながら
編集とかして今日の夕方までは乗り切り
たいと思いますでははい2日目の夕方です
だいぶ日が暮れてきましたお腹も結構減っ
てきたので2日目の食料会場行こうと思い
ますなのでお菓子食べたくないお菓子
めっちゃ食ってないジュースとめっちゃ
食べてますちょっと非常に体に良くないの
でしっかりした食べ物はあったら欲しい
ですただやっぱゴミ捨てるのってやっぱお
菓子が多いからねちょっと気をつけていき
たいと思います
やばいもうなんかゴミ見つけたら俺怖いん
だけどもうこんなに分かりやすく
でもありがたいかもご覧ください
シャキシャキとした食感濃い味の香り
ベビーフミックスなるほどねしっかりした
ご飯が食べたいとは言いましたがかなり
緑ミドルDC感じにはなってますね
要するに
腐ってことでしょまあでもか結構
ありがたいです野菜全然食べれてなかった
から
マスクしてんなボケてきただけよ
おいおいおいおいおいおい
うわあこれでもこれだけだと判断ができ
ないのでノーカウントダウンもう
[音楽]
ちょいしっかりして欲しかったなこれ
割とこの地域のお菓子のゴミは俺殲滅した
気がするからあと味噌汁と米と副作用だけ
はやだよこれはどうですか
これ多いお茶のホットですよ本当にはい
わかるのでホットゲットしましたもう少し
行くとコンビニがあるのでそこら辺
なんかゴミとかあったらちょっといいなと
は思うよくはないんですけど
[音楽]
[拍手]
こんなとこに挟まってやがるひどいこと
するなマジで
でもでかいぞこれ
セブンス
ミニほっぺさんのゲットです
これ期間限定とかじゃないよね裏見たら
賞味期限2月なんだけど今3月よちょっと
売ってるかどうかわかんないこれ売って
なかったらもうダメですかはいはい
綺麗だね
[音楽]
すごいよねここ
ら辺くるっとしてみました買ってすぐ
捨てるみたいなアホみたいなやつがいたら
絶対あるはず
どこにもないですねゴミがすごいいいこと
なんですよハッピーなことなんですけども
僕が食べれないっていうね
[音楽]
これ買えないから無理ってことでしょはい
食いたかったな
[音楽]
これどっちの判断だ絶対あのファースト
フードなんですよ変えてねえから商品名が
あれば勝ちってことでしょ
絶対
さっきの
繋がったさっきけどケチャップと
マスタードぶっかけてポイしてここであの
フランク作って食ってポイしたんですよ
これ絶対ちょっと商品名がないということ
は
ダメですはい
おいおいおいおいタバコかよコンビニ周り
超綺麗です明日とか不安なんだけど結構
どうしよう明日何もなかったら公園寄って
もいいですか結構
[音楽]
暗いです2日目にしてマジで食料がない
おいおいおいおいおいおいおいおいおい
おいおいおいおいおいおいおいこれは
おにぎりだ特定できれば俺のもんだ
おにぎりのこだわり卵のマヨネーズしよう
明確な頻度くらいいやでもこれは多分シー
チキンマヨですこれ間違いないですセーフ
です
[音楽]
これはファミリーマートかなファミリー
マートたばこサンドです海最高みんな海
最高だよな
盛り上がっていこうぜ
ゴミ捨てんだよ
どうも2日目の夜ご飯ですなんかのイチゴ
のセブンのやつは多分期間限定だったので
売ってなかったですなし
久々の野菜ですねベビー水洗いして
くださいなるほどなるほどその水洗いして
から食べましょう
薬効くなこれホットのお茶もうまい
ツナマヨおにぎりがまさか食べれるとは
なぁ今日ちょっと見つかんないと思った
けど結構ちゃんと主役級が集まりました
いただきます
[音楽]
卵サンド
うまい
ごちそうさまでしたバランスよく食べる
ことができましたお菓子のゴミがね
ちょっと拾いすぎでもうほぼ壊滅してます
今日メインディッシュ系も全部回収し
ちゃったんで最終日がマジで何が見つかる
かわかりません頑張っていきますおやすみ
なさい
おはようございます3日目です3日目の朝
じゃか雨が降ってるんですけども3日目に
来ましたこれ何がすごいかというと感触
なくなるんですよ余計なもの一切食べれ
ないからなんかすごい食事のリズムが整っ
てきつつも結局朝お腹すくので早速集めて
いこうと思いますただもうね
ゴミないんよマジでないゴミも公園もない
もんでもなかったですねやばいどうしよう
どうしよう
てか1日目にさたくさんいて行けなかった
小さい方の公園行こうあーいいですね
[音楽]
[拍手]
見ろ見ろ
チョコチップクッキーだ
チョコチップクッキーゲットです
クラフトコーラ道はサイダーのクラフト
コーラ
[音楽]
飯は
カバーペーパーキャンディーこれなんか
駄菓子屋さんとかで売ってるやつ
でもゴミやっぱ多いぞこうやんふざけんな
よ二度としてるなよちょっと待って
ちょっと待ってやばい
ccでも
やばいもう飲めんもう飲めんなちょっと
待ってくれる
やばい飲めちゃったやばいの追いだったよ
これ
はいはいはいはいはいはいはいはい
これはちょっと個人的に必要なやり方です
ね
もうゴミは落ちてない感じがします
茶色ちょっと偏ったな
昨日の夜がちょっとまともすぎてもうほぼ
実質コロッケしかないみたいな感じだな
いただきます
[音楽]
ちょうどいい後味めっちゃさっぱり何これ
うまいな
[音楽]
ごちそうさまでしたというわけでお菓子は
ちょっと編集中に食べようと思います
[音楽]
3日目の夜ご飯を探しに行きたいと思い
ます結構雨降ってます近くに多分もうない
よやばい夜がマジでやばいです何かしら
見つかれば勝ち行ってきます家の周り見る
かいやーないですねーいやもう海海行き
ます最後
ビッグボーナス発見だこれはなんだ7の癖
になる
濃厚な
旨辛チリ味のポテチゲットしましたこれ
昨日なかったよねなかったですねこんな
1日で食えるんだポテチしてるやつ他の
ゴミとかもありますねちょっと海の方
行こうか俺は
ピザが食べたい飲み物はなんとかありまし
たねこれ
よくこんな平気で擦れるなマジで神経を
疑いますよ午後の講座のミルクティー
ポットです
[拍手]
7のお酒ですねクリアクーラー
ストロングレモンラムサワー
最終日にふさわしい確かにね勝利の店まで
雨どぎつくね
[音楽]
ちょっと待って待って待ってマジ無理
めっちゃ
擦ってるやんこの人ファミマの天然水これ
でいいでしょうかはい勝ち組のぶどう以上
ですやばいってーまとめてしてるなー
マジクズじゃんこれ絶対反抗的なあれだよ
ね
これありですかねこれはありですこれ
マックの一口チュロスだってこれありです
どっちだよこれも絶対今日の犯行だよね
一昨日なかったからマックのチュロス
ゲットです
まじでけえこれは
諦めかけたその時だったね
飲み物を飲み物というわけで3日目最終目
の夜です
日付が変わりそうです夜ご飯っぽいもの
ちょっとなかったけども
期間限定だけど待って良かったわ一口
チュロス
少ないけどこれマジうまいんだよな今から
ポテトチップスレモンライムサワーの
ストロング缶見つけた飲み物ですねえっと
カルピスがホットがもう売ってなくてこれ
になっちゃいました
玄米ちゃんはもうなんか期間限定かわかん
ないですけど売ってなくて揃えられない
もの以外は全部揃えさせていただきました
これが最後の晩餐ですいただきますまずは
これ
いただきますいや飲み物飲まないとマジで
この後撮影あるんだけどね3日間に乾杯
まともなもの食べれてないけども
意外と落ちてるものでなんとかなることが
分かりましたね
[音楽]
買ってきてもらったんですけども長さを
測ったところゴミの方がちょっと大きいん
ですねロング缶ですね
[音楽]
じゃあこれは圭介に飲ませますはいポテチ
いただきます
[音楽]
こういうペースってことでしょ
こういうこと
飯までたどり着けがここでしっかり
示さなければねおいゴミ捨てたゴミだもん
お前らこそがゴミだお前たちがゴミを捨て
たせいでこんなことになってんだ俺はどう
考えてもポイってゴミ捨てに乗っても許さ
れることではないので俺は全否定します逆
に捨ててなかったら成り立たなかった
きっかけではあるのでゴミがあって良かっ
たなっていうちょっと変な感情もありつつ
なくなった方がいいかなっていうでもこれ
どう考えても俺はご飯食べたいもう自分の
ためにゴミを集めなきゃいけないっていう
いい企画
めちゃくちゃなんかいい企画だった気がし
ます俺ただ飯探してただけなのに近所の人
に偉いねって褒められたからはい皆さん
これポイ捨てしなくなったらこの企画で僕
は餓死することができるのでぜひ皆さん
ボイスはしないようにしてください
[音楽]
あもう無理か
このペースじゃ飲めマジで正確にはこちら
でした500mlです
うまい
[音楽]
きついな炭酸が最終日にこんな地獄が待っ
てたぞマジで
[音楽]
意外と飲めるんやな人間ってロング缶
いただきます
[音楽]
乾杯
これ以上お酒までが高かった
[音楽]
あとは水だけです
というわけで全部
飲みました
[音楽]
やめてくださいそれだけ